okay welcome everyone for anyone who
doesn't know me I'm anne-marie white and
I'm the library director of the oliver
wolcott library in Litchfield
Connecticut and tonight we are happy to
have Raymond Lear see here tonight
Raymond Lear C is a former commodities
trader who has been studying and
researching oil issues for more than a
decade
he's written in New York Times the
National Review he's been interviewed on
CNN Fox News and in more than 15
different radio programs he's also a
member of the Wilson Council at the
Woodrow Wilson international center for
scholars and tonight he's here to talk
about his book over a barrel breaking
the Middle East oil cartel welcome
Raymond merci thank you Anne Marie this
is a rather complex subject and I mumble
a lot so I hope you'll all be patient in
the harsh old days of Britain's Royal
Navy sailor caught stealing extra rum
was trust over a barrel of a cannon and
left to broil in the Sun waiting to be
flogged figuratively speaking you and I
and everyone else in the oil consuming
world are already caught in such a
predicament instead of a cannon though
ours is a barrel of oil and the people
who put us there are members of the OPEC
oil cartel profit ears who have been
flogging us for years with no end in
sight there is a mystique surrounding
oil is a deliberate one trumped-up to
make everyone thankfully accept a
manipulated market with hugely inflated
prices these market machinations robbed
the world's consumers
of literally hundreds of billions of
dollars every year both from higher
energy prices as well as artificially
inflated costs for just about every
other kind of good over the past three
decades according to one US government
estimate the tab has totaled a
staggering seven trillion dollars in
fact prominent members of OPEC openly
work to undermine the democratic ideals
in the United States in other Western
countries tens of billions of Saudi
Arabian and Kuwaiti money go to finance
schools mosques and supposedly
charitable organizations that actively
provoke promote the virulent ly anti
Western Wahhabi strain of Islam and
encourage Muslim citizens of Western
nations to reject the principles on
which their governments were founded
ironies abound not least that we supply
the money that buys the textbooks and
prayer books stuffed with venomous words
scripted to inspire burying us American
citizens gas money is used to pay the
salaries of iman's and school officials
who propagate the poison but it isn't
only the hate-filled teaching and
preaching that we support the sheer
volume of this torrent of funds
practically guarantees that some of our
dollars will wind up in the hands of
people both stateless terrorists and
recognized leaders of rogue nations who
are capable of acquiring biological
chemical or nuclear weapons of mass
destruction and eager to use them
against us Iran at this moment is
pursuing a program to arm itself with
nuclear weaponry and in consequence if
past is prologue make them available to
terrorist organizations
Asians as well we must finally recognize
understand and speak clearly about the
grave danger and risk that radical Islam
presents to our lives to our national
security and we must fully understand
that OPEC is the malign paymaster of
radical Islam their greatest
cheerleaders OPEX greatest cheerleaders
have been Western oil companies who have
run interference for OPEC all the while
playing up our fears conditioning us to
expect imminent shortages and supply
disruptions convincing us that oil and
gas prices are reflection of a free and
unfettered market forces and generally
singing OPEC song the more successful
OPEC is at ratcheting up prices the more
money flows to the bottom line of the
major oil companies and the smaller ones
alike in doing so in helping OPEC
achieve their target of ever higher
crude prices they have in their way
become co-conspirators and enablers of
conditions that pose grave risk to our
national security by encouraging these
excessively high prices for crude oil
they are making possible the transfer of
enormous wealth to regimes who spend
tens of billions of their oil wealth
exporting their intolerant and violent
Wahhabi religious teachings and funding
radical Islam the price of crude oil is
key to the issue of national security
and we must begin to understand the
distinction that must be drawn between
the price of crude oil and the price of
gasoline the greater the price of crude
the greater the profits to oil companies
but much more ominously the much more
ominously the
rated the transfer of wealth to regimes
that pray for our demise the price of
gasoline on the other hand entails
issues of environmental concern it is
time we separated the two crude oil and
gasoline in determining national
security energy and environmental
policies closely related but their
ramification in each of these categories
are vastly different high crude oil
prices should not be the determinant of
an environmental policy that calls for
high gasoline prices that is a role we
should forge for ourselves understanding
the less we pay for crude the greater we
safeguard our national security all this
is taking place in a miasma of obscure
and purposeful disinformation meant to
feed fear nothing moves markets like
fear one oil industry wag was precisely
quoted some years back this information
meant to feed fear of supply constraints
not to speak of varied scenarios of
supply disruption quote Western nations
are not dealing with oil producers as
partners why should they have the
advantage of knowing details of oil
producers reserves data is information
and information is power was the
response of an advisor to the Saudi
government to the group of seven finance
ministers request in February of this
year for greater transparency on the
part of oil producers of their reserves
and production capacity OPEC has
skillfully played the trumped-up Cod of
limited production capability to
purposefully restrain production and to
rationalize the march to high prices
excuse me OPEC as I said is a cartel
but not just any cartel it is the
world's most egregious combine and its
most damaging it blatantly violates the
spirit of free trade as well as the
rules of the World Trade Organization
while being meekly thanked by its hold
of victims over the years OPEC has used
the inherent angst of the markets to
process and exacerbate hype as a cover
to raise prices another knotch
again and again whether it be political
turmoil regional strife to your
political concerns strikes and rebellion
whether of inclement Andreo programmed
hysteria is orchestrated to sweep away
real facts and the price of oil marches
inexorably upward please understand that
in today's world the minute-by-minute
price of crude oil is set on the futures
market be it in New York London or
Singapore these trading exchanges are
presumed to reflect a true level of
supply and demand in world markets
thereby establishing free and fairly
negotiated prices yet what is not fully
understood is that trading is virtually
unregulated that trading is basically
opaque one doesn't know who is buying or
selling and this lack of oversight and
transparency lends itself to
manipulation by those who have the means
and the interest in pushing prices mock
in pushing market prices higher or lower
OPEC and/or its members have a keen
interest in pushing prices higher
and certainly they have the means to do
so given the billions being cashed in
daily in this booming oil market but
beside an example last December after a
slight fall back in prices Saudi oil
minister and erstwhile president of OPEC
alia Nighy me predicted on December 12
watch what happens tomorrow I tell you
prices will go up tomorrow and with some
unusual gyrations during the trading day
indeed they did putting his reputation
on the line the only way Alan ie me
could have been so certain that prices
would move as predicted as if either he
his agents the Saudi oil company Aramco
or OPEC and their agents traded and
manipulated the oil futures market on
that day and if indeed the oil futures
markets were manipulated on that day it
raises the much larger question of when
before and since to what effect
and how often here is an issue that
virtually crowd as it cries out for
congressional scrutiny most especially
in that the price of crude oil is the
largest component by far in the price of
gasoline in March of 1991 after the end
of the first Iraq war I wrote an op-ed
piece for the New York Times asking did
we fight the war to save OPEC it argued
that OPEC was restraining global trade
and imposing and unfair tax on the world
economy I suggested that since we had
saved Iraq and protected Saudi Arabia
from Saddam Hussein the least those
countries could do in return was to exit
Peck and trade their oil on a
free-market basis yet OPEC continued to
spread its propaganda and hardly anyone
spoke up in protest least of all the
cartels friends in Washington and other
world capitals a decade later the United
States again went to war with Iraq the
uncertainty and fears of an oil supply
crisis push prices to unimaginable
OPEC happily fed the panic in September
of 2003 the cartels chief propagandist
ibrahim al Maliki by him wrote a
remarkable letter to the International
Herald Tribune that reached a new level
of hubris and hypocrisy he said the
cartel was ensuring the steady flow of a
finite resource at a price that is fair
and reasonable and thus doing nothing
less than quote filling our obligations
to humanity unquote Ibrahim went on to
claim that the Western nations were
quote the biggest beneficiaries of high
oil prices since unquote since the oil
companies were headquartered in these
countries and OPEC spent its oil riches
on Western goods and investments his
brazen claim that OPEC was good for all
humanity prodded me to write another
piece OPEC Follies the breaking point
which was published by National Review
Online in December 2003 after which I
began writing my book in a brave and in
a remarkably candid public observation
reported by the BBC the UK's Chancellor
of the Exchequer Gordon Brown on
September 11th this year blasted OPEC
for the causing of the doubling of price
of crude oil over the previous 18 months
an unusually blunt language on this
issue it coming from a public official
of such prominence he spoke a truth for
which he was immediately chastised by
OPEC and their hires in the public
relations world symptomatic of the
problem and the lack of scrutiny focused
on this core issue barely a newspaper or
journal in the United States picked up
his comment Gordon Brown's comments
validated one of the main theses of my
book that OPEC has been the key
instrument in manipulating the price of
oil by over 600% from a price of close
to $10.00 per vowel some six years ago
to over $70 at the end of August a jump
a jump of this magnitude in this fight
in this time frame is virtually unheard
of for a commodity of such wide
distribution and to my view is prima
facie evidence of market manipulation
the cartel must be broken and the United
States must lead the fight our
government alone carries the clout to
stand up to OPEC and the oil interests
their powerful friends and well
entrenched allies and the accumulated
billions of dollars that bought bankroll
their activities the time has come for
our leaders to honor their commitment to
this nation by coming down squarely on
the side of its people and not simply
the oil patch
they must defend us against the greed
and destructiveness of OPEC and it's
minions in the oil and related industry
anything less will be a dereliction of
duty thank you sure I read in the paper
was it maybe last week about our own
mobile oil having a tremendous profit
how do you figure that into the market
manipulation
well if Mobil Oil ExxonMobil and BP for
example another oil company colluded to
fix prices the heads of those companies
mr. Lee Raymond and um the chairman of
BP would find themselves behind boz in
short order what they would be doing by
colluding would be against our antitrust
laws and punishable severely but they
don't have to do that you see
OPEC does it for them OPEC controls 40%
of the world's oil production and in a
commodity is large and is widely
distributed as crude oil if you Co if
you control 40% of that particular
commodity you can control the price so
what Mobil has been fortunate in doing
they don't have to collude they just
piggyback their profits on OPEC Mobil
Exxon Mobil are large producers of crude
oil as well so all I have to do is
follow the price of OPEC as the more
successful OPEC is and increasing prices
they just follow it up and their bottom
line becomes becomes bigger and better
and fatter
yeah I saw an interesting sign once it
said how did our oil get under their
sand can you explain that uh it's I have
a chapter in my book that deals a little
bit you know not quite as explicitly
with that issue but you have to remember
that there was once upon a time
something called the Seven Sisters of
oil companies that basically they were
the the the masters of that oil they
they sort of dictated what price the oil
would be sold what the participation
would be of the of the national entities
of where that oil was being where that
oil was being drilled and production and
everything was really dictated by these
seven sisters and there was an enormous
the the relationship was so difficult at
at a given moment that the producing
countries got together and created this
creature called OPEC so they OPEC is in
a sense a reaction to the question you
asked a logical reaction that if the
Seven Sisters which is which I think the
Bush family was a member of that Seven
Sisters oil cartel is it OPEC just
another cartel and reaction to the
initial cartel and you that'd be a
logical thing to do to sort of protect
your own resources in your own
environment in your own your own people
my my book goes into goes into chapter
and verse on that but what I'm trying to
sort of underline is that OPEC has
stashed the sized into something
grotesque into something that is beyond
beyond the general understand
ending of how dangerous it has become
not only to our economy but to our
national security the roots of it the
reaction to the Seven Sisters you know
it's hard to argue with that but what is
it today and what is it doing today and
what is it doing to us and what is it
doing to the world economy that's that's
the point of this book you're blaming
OPEC for all prices right I'm saying
that their control of the market but the
second third fifth largest exporters of
oil in the world are not members of OPEC
and how you explain that that sound like
control so second library or the United
States is a major exporter Canada's a
matrix all right well well I think it's
it's a variation of the first question I
answered you have to realize that the
oil producers that is to say the oil
patch where they're sitting in Moscow
whether they're sitting in Calgary
whether they're sitting in Washington
they are all OPEX greatest cheerleaders
the more successful OPEC is the more
money they make
because OPEC is really sort of you know
they're they're the front line of their
sense in their view they're the front
line of oil prices and the better that
OPEC can ratchet up prices the more
money flows down to the bottom line of
all these companies so when you know
they go before a Senate Congressional
Committee and say well you know it's the
market it's not us it's the market that
is forcing these prices well yes and no
they're doing a lot in the meantime to
sort of form our opinion to invest us
with with
with all sorts of dubious facts like you
know we're dealing with a free market
it's not a free market it's a totally
manipulated market and yet we all
believe it's a free market they also
tell us we're dealing with a commodity
that you know is is in relatively short
supply and we'll be running out of it
we've been running out of oil since you
know since Pennsylvania was the leading
oil producer in the United States and
every few years we come up with the same
argumentation I go into a lot of detail
in my book you know trying to deal with
that particular argumentation both of
them and trying to clarify why you know
it is part of the part of the of the oil
patch mantra that is trying to view this
rationalization for really extracting
money out of our pocketbooks I was
interested in knowing how much of the
ratcheting up of the price you've talked
about six hundred percent jump in ten
years
can be attributed to the growing economy
of China and its demands on this
resource let me let me give let me
answer that by giving you an example of
something China you know is not
Luxembourg out there everybody knows is
there everybody follows the economy of
China everybody knows what is happening
there everybody can more or less gauge
in some measure what the potential of
China is in terms of a consumer in terms
of its needs OPEC has been telling us
that they are straining to produce and
to meet world demand today and they're
producing something like 30 million
barrels of oil a day and they are you
know we are going around thanking them
and appreciating enormously and deeply
and profoundly the efforts they're
mating
making
to to meet the demand of China and India
and so on in 19 1979 1979 over 25 years
ago
OPEC produced 31 million barrels of oil
a day so you mean to tell me that all
these very smart people with all this
money and all the access that they have
could not have figured out somehow that
there was going to be more demand in a
given direction and have been able as
good world citizens you know adjusted
their production capability and be in a
position to be producing 40 million
barrels of oil or something like that
today no they didn't they purposely kept
it tight because by keeping it tight
they can demand high prices and we let
them keep in sight you're calling on our
government leaders to help break this
cartel control do you have any thoughts
about what they might do um I hate to
keep on referring to the book but I do
have a chapter of possible solutions
that you know I put forward none of
these solutions are easy they all
require an enormous amount of both
political and public will and you know
my the key point is that OPEC has been
able to control supply we have done
absolutely nothing at our end to control
demand we're you know it's like we're at
a poker table and they know what our
cards are and we don't know what their
cards are they purposely obfuscated you
know what their reserves are with their
production capabilities etc etc what
they know you know how many cause we
have and what our usage is and so on and
so forth
we have to be serious we have to begin
to understand that we are facing a grave
a grave economic and national security
crisis here
and that we have to take our destiny
into our own hands both in terms of
safeguarding our nation and also to to
to rekindle a level of self-respect that
I think we're losing because of this
issue
we're like drug I honest addicts who
have lost control a number of the issues
that I do touch on and I realize how
difficulties are they are is a voucher
program where the government say sets a
given level of gasoline consumption for
every quarter or every six months and
issues issues vouchers throughout the
country you know with the new technology
or what-have-you we can we can determine
whether somebody in the arc is you know
should get so much and somebody in Marfa
Texas should get so many vouchers so
that there is a certain equilibrium and
a certain fairness and that we really we
we encourage diminishing the the level
of of consumption of fossil fuels I mean
much of our much of that consumption is
discretionary anyway and we can then use
these vouchers we don't like him you
know like I may decide to you know not
use my car use a bicycle I'd be able to
sell my vouchers to the guy who has the
Hummer down the street you know and and
if he wants to buy them or otherwise
he's just going to be able to go so far
in his Hummer because he just has so
many vouchers for his particular vehicle
the I whole concept of vouchers would
automatically overnight change the way
we relate to to travel to mass transit
to the size of cause we drive etc etc
and if we were able to reduce in my
opinion at least for my trading days we
were able to reduce a 10 percent we
consume 21 million barrels of oil a day
we were able to reduce that I tell you
by 10 percent
we probably knocked down the price of
oil by $30 a barrel
I think you're certainly onto something
as far as controlling demand the voucher
system does make me a little nervous
having just finished teaching 1984 who
decides who gets the vouchers as a
problem but what the demand piece
absolutely well I mean it's you know I'm
a free-market person and I would never
recommend that in a free market
situation but we're dealing with with a
manipulated market so we have to on our
end do some things that counter veil
that oh excuse me
it occurs to me that a small part of the
solution to the problem could be and my
alternative forms of energy and I
personally M don't understand why these
aren't being developed more quickly or
with more vigor and do you think there's
some pressure from behind the scenes or
from effect where the cartels that
inhibits the growth of this or
encourages people not to develop these
alternative forms there where the
pressures come from there are
environmental pressures in terms of
additional drilling in the United States
offshore and Anwar my opinion is where
we can get oil we should get it and
reduce our dependence as much as we can
but there are alternative energy
biofuels and things like that which
certainly you know in Brazil most cos
are made in such a way that they can
burn both gas gasoline and ethanol or a
combination of the two you know and also
there is the option of nuclear energy
which again you know runs into
resistance you know from people who are
involved with the environmental movement
but again here you have you have you
have to recognize that France produces
80% of its electrical energy through
nuclear power and China is going to
quintuple
it's its production of nuclear energy
for electrical power etc over the next
15 years which means they're going to be
they're going to be building 40 nuclear
plants we have not built a single
nuclear plant since the mid 1970s that
there are problems with nuclear energy
that goes without reason I mean that
goes without question excuse me but but
the one of the alternatives
I mean we're facing a real crisis we're
facing an economic crisis here and we
are facing a national security crisis if
we continue shipping boatloads of money
over to parts of the world that are
unstable and really pray for our demise
I mean we may get if we continue the way
we are and I don't want to be overly
alarmist but we may be visited with
nuclear energy in a form that we don't
even want to think about risk to
discourage drilling in Alaska you know
that's a hot political football and you
know our friends you don't have to go
further in new york times to to give you
you know all the reasons why they feel
it's inappropriate you know again how
deeply they look at the whole global
problem
I don't know but certainly we really
should be doing everything we can to
diminish our dependence on on oil from
unstable resources I just have a quick
question because the relationship
between the Bush family with the Saudis
and even the Carlyle Group supporting
this president's early jobs is this the
more dangerous administration than
normal and confronting what we have to
confront in front of us right now with
this oil situation
well I go into I mentioned both the
Carlyle Group in the book and I also
mention the an incident that happened in
the mid 80s that basically made us the
protectors of OPEC which is really what
I call the Faustian bargain that we made
at that time and I think we got the raw
end of that particular deal but let me
turn that around
you know George Bush our president is a
man who comes from the oil industry the
industry was bred in the bone his man
who understands the people knows the
people in the industry knows the people
in the industry overseas I would like to
hope that that he would use this
knowledge to really help lead us out of
the wilderness because we are in a
wilderness right now it would really
help define his presidency and help to
really change a lot of perceptions about
about many things and I would like to
and there's probably no what no one
better equipped to do that in our
government right now than our current
president nobody is so deeply wedded to
this industry and nobody is so deeply
knowledgeable about this industry if we
would only use it to help us all out of
the situation we're in I didn't hear the
question you say we should reduce our
dependence on the OPEC oil I agree with
you but how when I toured the Valdez
installation of Alaska several years ago
I was told that most of the Alaskan oil
was going to Japan so unless our
government can't control where our own
oil goes to how do you propose reducing
our dependence on the OPEC oil
well oil is a it's a fungible commodity
which means that I'm sure the way things
work what the oil companies get for
selling the oil in to Japan out of
Alaska uh makes it possible for them to
buy oil from sources where the
transportation costs may not be as high
as it is from Alaska are these things
all sort of work themselves out in in in
ways where considerations of of ocean
freight costs and things like that are
sort of become paramount it is it's a
question that's frequently raised and it
is a question that you know helps the
augmentation of well we're really
dealing with a free market here and
wherever oil goes it goes it's just you
know the marketplace determines what
happens and unfortunately again it's a
it's a cooked set of books because the
market is really set by the OPEC
countries and the fact that they ship
out of places that may be closer to the
eastern seaboard and Alaska is where the
oil comes from so the only differential
really ends up being one of the shipping
costs are you better off buying the oil
which is the same product say coming
from Nigeria or to ship to New Orleans
or you better off shipping it from
Alaska down to New Orleans to the
refineries down there and the trade-off
may be your shipping cost might be
slightly less shipping it you know from
Nigeria so you sell the Alaska oil and
you by the Nigerian oil don't I'm sorry
hi I'm having read your book I'm
interested in knowing what you think
about the recent rise and then fall of
both crude oil and gasoline prices
after Katrina and Rita and when it went
up and then in light of two things in
your book that you described one was
that President Bush he felt should
release some of our strategic oil
reserves which he did after Katrina and
also how you pointed out in your book
that refineries or the lack of refining
capacity was not really the issue here
and I think I heard that this there's
still quite a few refineries in the Gulf
area that are there are still not up
running and yet the price of crude oil
and the prices of gas at the pump seems
to me has gone down by you know on the
fact where it was before Katrina right
okay two questions and good questions
and thank you for asking them because as
I've said in you know in my little talk
here the oil patch uses all these
emergencies to hype up the price of oil
and even your question sort of reflects
one of the issues the price of oil crude
oil under Katrina asked after Katrina
went up to 70 dollars and 85 cents the
highest it has ever been and now it's
back down to about 59 58 dollars um
this had been part and parcel of the
game that the oil patch is played with
all of us here we are celebrating
celebrating the fact that the price of
oil has gone down by 12 dollars and it's
still you know instead of paying $25 for
an ice cream cone we're now paying $22
and 37 cents for an ice cream cone it
you know it is the way we have been
manipulated the way we have our minds
have been sort of set to respond to this
kind of up and then you know they take
the pressure off for a while I could
have sworn given the Congressional
Oh investigations or the congressional
hearings this week that the price of oil
and the price of gasoline was going to
go down and you wait and see if nobody
really touches on the issue in a few in
a few weeks time in a month or two it
will be right back up to over $60 a
barrel and right back to levels
approaching the Catrina levels and now
we're going to hear from now until
forever
well price of oil you know it's not at
the level of Katrina yet you know it's
it's only 68 dollars a barrel it's not
seventy dollars and 85 cents and this is
the kind of nonsense that we have really
been been fed and you know we you know
we're sadly were too gullible and these
people are too clever now as far as the
refineries are concerned here again you
know we're told we don't have refinery
couldn't believe it after
Prince Abdullah went down to Crawford
Texas there was a joint statement made
or at least the Saudis made a statement
that one of the problems with one of the
reasons that crude oil is so high is
because the United States has not really
built any refineries in 20 or 30 years
now if I if I have you know if you have
ten bakeries right and I'm I produce
flour and you close down two of those
bakeries I'm going to raise the price of
my flour I mean it just logically makes
no sense the less refinery capacity you
have the less requirement you have for
crude oil why should that be an excuse
for the Saudis to raise the price of
crude oil but where is it in the media
that those things are examined and
talked about and analyzed it doesn't
happen and then further as far as
refineries are concerned did anybody
tell you whether we're telling us that
you know we're we don't have enough
refinery capacity in this country
we don't have enough crude oil capacity
in this country what are we doing we're
importing gasoline we import heating oil
we import diesel oil and we've been
doing that for years and after Katrina
what happened is that all this gasoline
was imported into the United States so
that two weeks after Katrina our our
reservoir stocks of gasoline were
actually higher than they were before
Katrina so that whether the oil is
refined in the United States or refined
in god-knows-where is really secondary
but nobody really touches on those
issues you know and you don't have to be
a Nobel Prize laureate to to deal with
those things I don't get it that's one
of the reasons I wrote this book because
I've been waiting for somebody else to
write it please I'm sorry
somehow I don't have any secure feel
secure or feel confident that George
Bush is going to be the person who's
going to be the spokes the spokesperson
to the OPEC industry to make a change
here is there anybody besides mr. leer
see in this universe of ours who is
working against this imminent disaster
that you described in Washington I mean
are there are other people who are
cognizant of the potential hazard we're
facing I'm sure there are I'm sure there
are I would like to hope that President
Bush somehow will will see the light and
understand what has to be done for the
greater good of the nation but I caution
that between 1998 and 2004 the oil
interests gave over 440 million dollars
to political action committees to Senate
races two congressional races two
presidential races and that's only the
money that was reported that has nothing
to do with the money that goes to
lawyers in Washington to to lobbyists
etc etc which is massive so that if that
kind of money gains you access and
access gains influence what the people
of this nation do not have is the kind
of influence the oil patch has and
unless people really become cognizant of
this problem and understand this problem
and really deal with this problem with
their elected representatives nothing
much is going to happen you seem to be I
mean the title of your book over a
barrel seems to indicate that we're the
victims of OPEC and I would suggest that
we're victims of also the drug cartels
the Federal Reserve which manipulates
the interest rates in the drug cartels
which manipulates the the amount and
price of drugs so aren't the oil people
just playing the same game that
everybody else in the world is playing I
mean why are they why are you singling
them out as the bézier evil evil demons
uh I don't think Alan Greenspan is
running around looking for nuclear
weapons you know he he has other things
on his mind
and the dark cartel you know I I you
know there are certain I don't know
enough about the drug cartel to really
comment but certainly there should be
you know there's an analogy between
drugs and our dependency on oil maybe
it's the way things when people become
addicted to something that's what
happens in a in an economic construct um
and I you know it's the only thing I can
say I mean is that maybe there is a
parallel I don't think there's a
parallel with the Federal Reserve
bored though I'm sorry we were in Europe
last week it seemed like there was a lot
more anti-americanism in the media and
in the people on the street and one
thing the people told us was that they
blame America for the bad weather
because we did not sign the Kyoto treaty
and they feel that we are producing too
much carbon dioxide and that we're
responsible for pollution do you think
that Kyoto was unrealistically high so
that it would split Europe and the
Americans since it was impossible for us
to sign and OPEC had an interest in
making sure that America would be blamed
and that they would divide the West
between America and Europe so that we
could not stand against OPEC well I
think that's very Makaveli on but I
wouldn't put it past you know I wouldn't
put it past OPEC for you know concocting
something like that and seeing it
through Kyoto is is a problem of
perception I mean the United States is
is roundly criticized around the world
for for not having signed Kyoto but on
the other hand I think Kyoto if and I
may be mistaken but I believe Kyoto does
not require the the participation of
China nor India and you know I think our
government felt that that would put us
in such a competitive disadvantage that
we couldn't do it unless there was
participation by everyone on some of the
editorials I've read written by the
heads of the oil companies defending
their higher prices in that they intend
to use a significant portion of those
increased profits for developing further
national oil resources
uh let me just say that I would have
greater response and respect for that
position had it come voluntarily without
the spotlight of public opinion on them
they've been doing very well over the
last years and most of the money that
they've been on earning has been going
has been going to to to dividends to the
shareholders now that they feel under
pressure plus they are also you know
they're just swimming in money they feel
that they can be gracious and and do a
little bit of oil exploration and
development on the other hand there is
also a very interesting aspect of this
as much as they protest that this is a
free market one of the reasons that they
have done so little to expand their
production and go into exploration is at
least in my opinion is not because
there's a shortage of oil but because
there is an abundance of oil they know
that if they invest billions of dollars
whether it's the canadian tar sands or
you know the american west in offshore
drilling and things like that if they
invest billions of dollars and they
produce oil that has a basic cost of
twenty or thirty dollars or thirty five
forty dollars a barrel they know because
their oil people they know that the
saudis with all their massive reserves
or the kuwait ease or the iranians or
what have you or even potentially the
iraqis can start producing oil and bring
the price of oil back to 10 or $15 or
$20 a barrel they know that the oil is
there the or they know that the oil
can be produced they know that if the
Saudis really decide to produce oil in a
massive quantity they could break this
price easily so they don't want to risk
being exposed to a situation of abundant
supply of oil rather than going after
because if they knew there was no other
oil around believe me they'd be spending
every nickel going into going into the
production of oil if we as you say are
giving our money to OPEC establish
prices and that gets funneled into
terrorism we are therefore giving money
to for the seeds of our own destruction
why does OPEC use why does OPEC support
terrorism because it seems to me that
the OPEC leaders would realize that they
are simply feeding the destruction
forces of the people that are buying
their product well I don't what's the
relationship there well it the connect
is that the
hobby sect is in de facto the national
religion of Saudi Arabia and has many
followers throughout other countries in
the Middle East and of course once upon
a time and still does I'm sure in
Afghanistan and they have been using
they have been using their oil proceeds
to fund madrasahs schools mosques all
over the world whether it's Indonesia
the Philippines whether it's in Pakistan
whether it's in Chechnya whether it's in
London and now in France they have been
using this money to create a mindset and
to teach young people a form of Islam
that radicalizes them and makes them
easy targets to become the kind of
insanity that we see if people blowing
themselves up just to blow other people
up I mean it's a mindset that is a
plague unto the world and they have an
enormous amount of money to to propagate
that insanity and every day I mean you
you know every day there is just to give
you an example when Gordon Brown said
that the price of oil doubled a from 18
months prior to his statement in
September
it went from around $30 a barrel to
around $60 a barrel then or over $60 a
barrel that meant that every day the
difference in what OPEC was able to get
because of their manipulation that
additional $30 a barrel they produce as
I mentioned before they produce OPEC
produces 30 million barrels a day that
means that there is a transfer of wealth
to the OPEC countries each day of nearly
a billion dollars a billion dollars
and you know you have you have this this
mindset and these people who are
determined and who have this this
determination to to sort of confront to
confront Western standards in Western
ideas and they want to establish a
Caliphate throughout the world and they
want to make us victims why would they
fund organizations whose intent is to
destroy our civilization which is the
very civilization that's buying their
oil in their view I presume they feel
they have a higher calling you know the
money comes in that's a gift from above
and that money has to be used for what
their higher calling is now I'm just
play devil's advocate for a moment why
is cheaper price for all desirable
because all there's a commodity and like
any commodity of the cheaper it is the
more waste of it'll be used back when
gasoline was 25 cents a gallon the
average American Gaga may be 1012 miles
again and if you're lucky if for
instance if you take the washing up
water you wouldn't give a second thought
throwing it out but if you're in the
middle of the Sahara Desert three days
after the war pump just failed you
wouldn't throw it out well I realize I
as I said at the beginning I mumbled I
mumble and I think I mumbled in in in my
little text that we have to
differentiate between the price of crude
oil and the price of gasoline
we have to do whatever we can to press
down the price of crude oil and we have
to we don't want to create which we have
done we have environmental groups who
want high prices for crude oil because
it means high price of gasoline without
realizing what they're doing is funding
these unstable regimes and this national
danger that we're from that we're facing
so we have to decide ourselves what the
price of gasoline should be we can no
longer leave it completely to the free
market we have to decide what is in our
interest is it burning fossil fuels and
and global warming and things like that
and what is what does that mean in terms
of value and how does that come out in
terms of the price of gasoline but let's
keep the price of crude oil as low as we
can you're proposing is that the amount
of money which is making its way to the
Middle East is too large so the solution
is to is to make that differential
attacks redistribute into the United
States
absolutely okay absolutely yeah